by the way in the in the same vein as
rogan did you did you see this clip it's
only two minutes long but
you were telling me about it joe rogan
getting annoyed because neil degrasse
tyson keeps interrupting him
standing who and what we are in this
universe
we place great value on that so
but it's not our land it's with you know
so specifically these things
europeans didn't come to hawaii and find
find
legions of scientists there conducting
experiments okay
they found native peoples governing
themselves so
so so that's that the consequence all
right so
there are ways around problems if you
value the thing
that it is that you want to do so people
leaving crap up there you
make them bring it back or you develop a
system
that enables the stuff to come back no
matter what and if you can't do that and
you don't want it messed up then cancel
the whole
operation we didn't cancel cars we got
really innovative about how to keep them
a big difference between cars and human
[ __ ] that's left in the side of the
mountain
i think the real problem too is i think
if you
value mountain climbing
all right that was actually saw the
annoyance oh yeah he's going back could
you go back to this i just want to see
the
joe he was very annoyed at that one
watch ready
he's already annoying
did you see his face
this this this is great this is okay
okay
look at his look oh you mountain
climbing
yeah that is a [ __ ] and by the way i
you know we've been
fragging on rogan lately but i'm
completely on rogue oh yeah here you
have to be honest that's [ __ ]
annoying dude
i that's the most annoyed i've ever seen
joe rogan
the only time i've ever seen him close
to this annoyed was the jim norton phone
thing
which which was also obnoxious remember
when norton was
literally [ __ ] around on his phone
looking for tinder dates and [ __ ] and
rogan's talking and rogan's like
dude you want are you watching oh no no
i'm paying attention but like
it's it that is so rude for somebody to
be talking and be like
i'm saying i'm just listening like [ __ ]
when i hit people that do that let's
watch it in slow-mo
un-climbing
it is it is him
getting so annoyed
and you want to keep doing it then you
solve the problem
batteries as quick and look at rogue
look at rogan's attitude how it's
he's becoming more and more better
quickly as it in less time that it takes
to fill a tank
yeah you know how much time you stand
there with your hand on the nozzle
thinking like [ __ ] i helped make
you cool yeah
you're right how dare you how dare you
science [ __ ]
uh gas to go in right so they would have
to have a mountain of battery sitting
there waiting for people to just come in
is that any worse than a mountain that
than a than a
sunken reservoir tank of gas that's no
different
why is that any different probably
larger volume right
possibly but so what if it's economic
you just do it right
and if the battery's all at the bottom
of the car and
it's i'm getting really annoying you're
getting forged yeah i'm getting annoyed
like i'm not one to like wow that's
annoying
somebody's saying yeah well rogan does
everybody else so yeah but
that's fair and again to defend rogan
it's his show
does he interrupt a lot though he does
he'll do that
not as much as is [ __ ] like an alex
jones like if he were in there giving
alex jones a taste of his own medicine i
would be laughing
right be like ah well what's good for
the goose huh that looks like you have
to deal with it
but like i don't recall joe really ever
pushing it like that much with me this
is obnoxious
go like nascar you run in pop it up
take out the battery that's when you're
off do you think that's the future why
not
that's better than charging the battery
then a sunken reservoir tank of gas
that's no different
why is that any different probably
larger volume right
possibly but so what if it's economic
you just do it right
and if the battery is all at the bottom
of the car
and you go like nascar you run in pop it
up
take out the battery
a laboratory uh
stealth light
something try that yeah i found those
like uh
cloaks that people wear that sort of
seems like video yeah
yeah that seems like [ __ ] yeah
there's a lot of
but in harry potter
i'm getting mad for joe you're making me
want a white knife for joe rogan i don't
want to do that
and we don't crush enough puss to do it
really it's really as obnoxious
this is i want to oh my god i each
it's really bad right aren't you
supposed to go on a show right
and be like wow i'm humbled to be here
this is cool man thanks for the
opportunity
yeah cool miss what do you want to talk
about today you know and you want to
yeah okay there's time like it's
impossible to not talk over people
sometimes you're always you know people
in a conversation are just
always battling for a little bit of time
like this is just
this is just yeah it's like whatever ah
a buried gas tank okay i mean i just
it's now to the point where he's like
thinking i'm never having him on again
that's the i'm it's gonna be a while
before i have him on again face
yeah not never but but it'll be a while
the next book i'm gonna skip the next
book
and it'll be the book after that that
i'll have them on you know
you learn your lesson yeah it's you move
a couple tens of thousands of less units
and maybe next time you play ball
the was the cloak that they and that's
it that's that's pretty much the
that's pretty much that's obnoxious
though it really is right like that is
and it's his show again like i'm sure
rogan does interrupt people
but you can be forgiven when it's your
show right when it's a joe rogan show
you're gonna do that
um i guess but like i said i've never
seen joe do it like to the extent that
alex jones does where it's just where
it's like why is owen troyer even there
why is your guest even there